[Music]
hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight HBO's highest budget show
which which is a surprise until you
learn that everything you see including
me is entirely computer-generated and
come on how did you not figure that out
my face is textbook uncanny valley none
of this makes sense we are still on
hiatus this week but I wanted to briefly
return to speak about a very important
topic birds or as I call them cat
feeders birds are symbols of love wisdom
and of course human trafficking and and
as the weather cools down birds are
going to start their seasonal migration
where which is of course when they
travel to warmer climates in order to
feed grow and attract a mate it's their
version of Eat Pray Love accept birds
are too dumb to realize that everything
they needed was inside them the whole
time but before the migration begins I
have a brief message for the birds of
the Northeast as they begin their
journey southward
are you listening birds here goes q
birds q I hope you never come back
to me every single bird is just a shitty
sequel to the dinosaurs and we'd be
better off without you and yes I'm
talking to you
geese you look like ducks that play
football in high school and never
stopped going to the gym and you know
what you're not off the hook either
parrots Oh what I'm supposed to like
parrots just because they can talk
basically every human being talks and I
hate most of them
and while I'm at it ostriches you can go
straight to hell your first raft
flamingos you look like a giant ball of
lint trying to upshift
out a huge leathery snake oh oh and then
there are penguins yeah you guys are
actually fine I got no problem with you
penguins no problem but I'll tell you
what you get a Park lifetime pass for
you penguins but you know what you swans
and pelicans you both look like monsters
from a fish's nightmare that came to
life and as for hummingbirds you just
obese bees in need of a nose job
and you know what you know what actually
ostriches come back I'm not done with
you yet
your eggs are too big and and you look
like piñatas filled with grocery coupons
and drives meats just fly the away
from me oh I'm sorry you can't your
failures are the one thing birds are
known for now as for the rest of you the
rest of you birds I hope all you
disgusting sky mice enjoy your tropical
getaways while the rest of us face the
frigid torment of winter and I hope each
and every one of you
flies into a wind turbine on your way
north next spring yeah
oh ho skew Birds we are back on HBO
September 25th until then goodbye
you can fly away
[Applause]